[Musique]
ils d'entre vous n'a jamais visité les
huit mois je vis lillois qui n'a jamais
visité l'egypte où j'avais vite les
relais royal
il n'aura jamais ne serait ce qu'une
seule fois en déplacement
un lieu inhabituel ou choisir un
déplacement de l'unité de crise où
hormis le nettoyage est visé
[Musique]
ma mère devant aller chemise comme ou
d'entre nous ici en france
ouais c'était de devenir 8
mais la chance financier communion à
bully notre jargon populaire au québec
rabat le haut costumes et aux nuisances
mais aussi créer le déclic il aimait 9e
négation ou moi le travail est sur les
ressources naturelles
j'ai donc depuis cinq ans
mais véronique besse vertes' sur la
gestion durable des ressources
naturelles en ayant un accent
particulier sur la question mais god
touristique savoie l'ordination la
valorisation et la promotion des
potentialités les gouttes d'eau estime
désormais nommés j'ai appris récemment
sa alors l'animation internationales qui
nous lient le nourrissent constituent
10% du pib national
imaginez-vous je dis bien dix morceaux
du pays mais les paires nationale
[Musique]
ernational 1100 milliards de dollars en
essor
8 milliards de dollars
on les sent l'inflation en chine
[Musique]
évolutions du service
les formations aujourd'hui le
l'autorisent à huissen me levais le
nivellement leur mini aujourd'hui le
cloud
elles courront des l'économie mondiale
saviez-vous
dans le passé on a sonné au tourisme de
masse
mais lorsqu'il s'agit du tourisme de
masse cela a des conséquences sur le
plan social le livre en économie j'ai le
plan de l'environnement
l'on assiste à la destruction des
ressources natuelles aux eaux vives
construction estime l'ancien l'on
assiste au charme désuet au tourisme
sexuel
les mêmes à la junte réputation sur
blanc économique le nourrissent de passe
à conséquence une mauvaise rénumération
de la population à la base au profit de
nos opérateurs une compagnie de
transport mais compagnie hôtelière
heureusement aujourd'hui nous assistons
à une démission du tourisme grâce deux
en place
dont les goristes lui brise nicoli chic
oui vous savoir ce qu'est le tourisme
écologique le tourisme écologique un
tourisme axé sur la nature qui veut la
conservation des ressources naturelles
mais ressources mutuelles univers
ressources budget ayant une grosse
éducative lieu l'amélioration des
conditions de vie des populations
locales qui se retrouvent autour du
service mais j'ai vraiment une
expérience de jeu sous mais que vous
puissiez aussi la chimie ce que c'est
une expérience écotouristique jose luis
aduriz pour l'euro mais l'humour ne
voulait visiblement le stick de news ou
jouets a eu la chance de visiter les
nations unies aux prisons du men archi
l'étude de cette zone est récent je suis
né en 1918 a dormi dans l'histoire la
plus touchée du mois plus rude de vie de
paul marie je l'appuie sentir à chaleur
le séjour de josu et josué a pu admirer
le magnifique paysage de nuit le paysage
[Musique]
josué juin au lieu de ce message a aussi
né aux spécificités culinaires debout
mais je me parlait des poignets au
collège ou au lycée le grognon à vue
mais les mieux jouer
18 10 mai à l'innovation de dakar en
instruction
aviez vous un problème crucial de cette
communauté est le délaissement les
grosses trio traditionnel au profit des
gros section monnaie josiane en
commandant sont ses juges j'ai dû me
nettoie les difficultés de ces mausolées
aux cgu a déposé suivre lors du
déversement du vent mais l'art est
noirci merci neutre en ce moment et il a
convaincu que l'on reprend la renommée
mais avec tyr où ça me touche claque des
volontés sur a remercié à la population
locale à travers la construction des
brasses de tusson sur robin sonné
je vais parler des forages les sommes du
cinespace menace et messieurs voici ce
que c'est une expérience et logistique
le tourisme du futur l'envers à
l'économie le tourisme du futur le
norris route les effets des changements
climatiques et la gestion durable des
ressources naturelles pour les
générations futures un monde meilleur
le more is known by zégut 0 tourisme
exclusif avec ou sans les recettes sont
reversées à la population ramène la
constitution des astuces utiles aux
mines et le brise vue c'est le tourisme
préoccupations
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
plus démunis pour l'année de mes
objectifs de développement durable
mesdames et monsieur l'utopisme du futur
sédégo autorisé alors entre nous
les bretons reese a choisi
[Applaudissements]